oh no i definitely go for a second layer
i mean i designed bitcoin gold with two
layers because
one of the biggest mysteries and most
well-kept secrets of all time
is the true identity of the creator of
bitcoin
with an elias of satoshi nakamoto the
founder of bitcoin was able to create an
asset
whose market cap peaked at over 1
trillion dollars
if bitcoin was a company its market cap
would have been the sixth largest in the
world
at its peak yet somehow the founder has
been able to keep his identity
anonymous but if we look closer we'll
see that satoshi
actually left quite a bit of breadcrumbs
and one guy
even accidentally admitted for a brief
second that he created bitcoin
so here are the top contenders for
founder of bitcoin
and why the last contender may even be
satoshi himself
before we get into the candidates let's
first discuss why satoshi has chosen to
stay anonymous
we have seen theories that satoshi is a
private person who doesn't like
attention
or that satoshi has a criminal
background and doesn't want to attract
the attention of authorities
but in reality none of these are likely
the real reason
if you take a look at the premise of
bitcoin and comments from satoshi
the reason for this anonymity is clear
in 2011
satoshi wrote quote the root problem
with conventional currency
is all the trust that's required to make
it work so
one of the primary reasons bitcoin was
created was to prevent users from having
to trust the central authority or
figurehead
if satoshi's identity was revealed
people would look to him for his
thoughts on crypto
and they would look to him to fix any
issues but this would be contradictory
to the goal of bitcoin
in a decentralized system one person
should not be able to move the markets
and trust has to come from the community
not the creator
so that's why the creator of bitcoin
awards the spotlight
with that being said though amongst the
crypto community the ryo satoshi is
likely quite well known already
he or she is likely one of the most
respected voices
in the community this is because bitcoin
was not some random basement success
like many might think
in the first few years after bitcoin
went live satoshi was actually extremely
talkative
in fact he made 575 posts between
november 2009
and december 2010 these posts primarily
discussed problems with the bitcoin
and troubleshooting up various issues
with the help of the community
satoshi didn't leave the community until
he felt bitcoin or was ready
stating quote i have moved on to other
things it's in good hands with gavin
and everyone considering satoshi's
willingness to discuss bitcoin
with the community after the launch of
bitcoin it's highly likely that satoshi
was discussing with the crypto community
even before he created his elias so if
his identity was revealed one day
the general public would probably have
no clue who it is
but the people super involved in the
crypto space wouldn't really be
surprised
with that being said let's jump into our
first candidate which is of course
satoshi nakamoto himself the first
instinct you have when trying to find
the creator of bitcoin
is to actually find someone whose name
is actually satoshi nakamoto
and sure enough the media was able to
find a man named dorian satoshi nakamoto
but aside from having the same name and
being an engineer
this guy basically had no connection to
the crypto space he told the associated
press
i got nothing to do with it and
considering that it would be stupid to
use your real name if you wanted to be
anonymous
i think we'd all agree that he's telling
the truth moving on
we have elon musk again this one is an
oddball
though elon is extremely talented and
has a background to create such a
project
it's highly unlikely that it was elon
musk during the creation of bitcoin
elon musk had just burnt his entire
paypal fortune on tesla and spacex
and he was in debt just trying to get by
so i don't think he was spending his
free time
which he didn't even have coding bitcoin
next up we have craig wright
there's also very little evidence
suggesting that craig wright is indeed
satoshi
other than the fact that he himself
keeps claiming that he is satoshi
since 2016 craig has been claiming that
he was part of the main team who created
bitcoin
considering the philosophy of the real
satoshi however he would have likely
never come forward about being a founder
of bitcoin
along with craig we also have dave
clyman dave unfortunately died in 2013
and he never claimed to have created
bitcoin the only reason dave is on this
list is
because craig claims that dave was part
of a team but given that craig has low
credibility
no one really believes the story dave
was on satoshi's original mailing list
but it seems like craig is just
leveraging this connection to push his
own narrative
anyway with all those loose canons out
of the way we can move on to strong
candidates starting with braumcoin
braum is one of the veterans of the
peer-to-peer model having co-founder
bittorrent way back in 2004.
he was a prolific blogger who posted
about his thoughts on peer-to-peer
networks
security protocols and decentralized
systems coincidentally his blocking even
slowed down during the launch of bitcoin
braum was actually a super strong
candidate for founding bitcoin
but one of his later actions would
disprove this theory braum would
eventually go on to make his own
cryptocurrency called chia
and the chia is supposed to be the
anti-thesis to bitcoin and the
proof-of-work model used by bitcoin
i think we'd agree that it's highly
unlikely that satoshi would not only
trash on bitcoin
but also create a competing crypto
moving on we have gavin anderson
gavin anderson is a software developer
who was very much involved in the early
days of bitcoin
if you guys remember the last statement
from satoshi he said that bitcoin isn't
good hands with gavin and
everyone else it's possible that satoshi
was transferring the reigns to himself
a stylometry study even found that
satoshi's writing was most similar to
that of gavin anderson
an instant that raised some skepticism
about this theory was in
when gavin believed that craig wright
was the creator of bitcoin
though that seems a bit sketchy maybe
that was just a 200 iq play
it's possible that he saw craig take
credit for founding bitcoin and he went
along with the story to shift attention
away from himself
there isn't really any glaring evidence
that gavin isn't satoshi
the only reason i don't think is gavin
is because the last two people on this
list are even more convincing candidates
starting with hal finney paul finney
graduated with a computer science degree
from caltech in 1979
while completing his bachelor's he often
took graduate level classes
which really showcases his high
intelligence alfini was also the first
person to respond to satoshi's original
email
about bitcoin and how finney would
become the first person to connect to
satoshi's network
and the first to receive bitcoin
whenever you create a youtube channel
you're often your first subscriber and
whenever you create a business
you're often your first customer so it
could make sense that how finney was the
first test network and receive bitcoin
aside from having the brains of creative
project hal finney has a rather direct
connection to the name
satoshi nakamoto remember the first
guide that we discussed whose name was
dorian satoshi nakamoto
well he definitely wasn't the creator
but he may have very well been the face
of bitcoin
you see dorian just lived two blocks
away from hall finney
maybe hoffini used the name of his
neighbor to cover up his real identity
something else that fits the story is
that halfini was diagnosed with als in
and unfortunately died in 2014 this may
be the reason that satoshi nakamoto
stopped posting in 2011
and why we haven't heard from him the
only problem in this story
is that i'm not sure satoshi would have
made himself so obvious
would he have really made himself the
first recipient of bitcoin and
was he really emailing himself i'm not
sure
a lot of the crypto community actually
thinks that hal finney is indeed satoshi
nakamoto
and i wouldn't be surprised if it really
was him or if he was one of the key
players
but i do think one man isn't even like
their candidate
and that's of course nick sabo most of
you guys
likely aren't familiar with nick sabo
but he was one of the first people in
the crypto space
if not the first nick proposed the idea
of digital currency way back in 1998
with the name bit gold the idea for big
gold was basically
identical to bitcoin bitgold relied on a
network of decentralized miners to
verify transactions
and keep the system secure nick sabo
never ended up launching big gold
because he wasn't able to work through a
handful of security risks
but that doesn't mean that he ever
stopped trying it in a 2005 blog post
nick actually outlines how an
unforgeable chain or the blockchain
was a solution to his problems with big
gold in this post
nick also explains how the entirety of
the big gold system would work
from mining to transactions to the
blockchain what's extremely surprising
is that despite spending seven years
figuring all of this out nick didn't end
up launching bit gold
what's even more fishy is that he tried
to make it seem like he made this blog
post
after bitcoin was revealed if you take a
look at the publication date of this
blog post
it says december 27 2008 at the top but
if we use a wayback machine we can see
that a snapshot of the website was taken
in 2006
which showcases that the original date
of publication was december 29
2005. internet detectives also confirmed
that there was actually no change to the
post itself
except for the display date of
publication aside from outline the
entirety of bitcoin before it actually
came out
nick sabo was the only crypto enthusiast
who never communicated with satoshi
nakamoto
as we previously discussed satoshi
nakamoto had communicated with gavin
anderson
and hal finney but he never communicated
with the nixabo
despite nick being one of the veterans
of the space the initials of satoshi
nakamoto
are also the same as nick sabo in japan
when you write initials you write the
last name first
meaning that satoshi's initials are ns
not sn
satoshi even commented on how his
bitcoin address started with his
initials
and sure enough his bitcoin address
starts with ns not
sn around the time bitcoin came out
nick's blogging also fell off a cliff
between 2005 and 2008 he was averaging
40 posts every single month
since 2009 however his posting has been
doled to 30 to 40 posts
per year something else to consider is
that nick even had a copyright on the
idea for big gold
yet despite bitcoin being basically a
ripoff of bit gold
nick never took any legal action against
bitcoin
i think it's safe to assume that if you
spend 10 years developing bitgold
and some japanese dude with an opposing
history in the community comes along and
rips off your work
you would almost definitely pursue legal
action satoshi even admitted that
bitcoin is implementation of wei dei's b
money proposal
and nick sabo's bitcoin proposal i mean
this seems like the perfect opportunity
to sue
another coincidence is that nick's
birthday and satoshi's birthday or both
april 6th
but by far the strongest piece of
evidence is a potential freudian slip
from
nick a freudian slip is an unintentional
error that reveals a person's
subconscious thoughts
these are especially common when a
person is trying to suppress a thought
for instance if i told you not to think
about dolphins the first thing you'll
think about
is dolphins every time you try not to
think about dolphins
you'll end up thinking about dolphins
the same idea applies here with nexabo
in an interview with tim ferriss in 2017
nick accidentally says that he designed
bitcoin
and then quickly corrects himself oh no
i definitely go for a second layer i
mean
i designed bitcoin gold with two layers
because evidently
nick may very well be the satoshi
nakamoto
even if he isn't though he's still no
doubt the father of bitcoin
as he developed bitcoin years before
bitcoin ever saw the light of day
do you guys think nick sabo and hal
finney are the creators of bitcoin
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys found this video
fascinating and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one